esta primera jornada de la segunda ronda
aquí en Roland garros por ahora no nos
ha dejado grandes sorpresas Carlos
Alcaraz uno de los grandes favoritos
para conseguir el título aquí consiguió
su pase a la siguiente ronda a pesar de
haber cedido un set a la japonesa taro
Daniel partido de dos horas veinticinco
minutos y cuatro sets para el español
que en la siguiente ronda ha de
enfrentarse
en la búsqueda de su título es el griego
Stefano quien en tan solo tres sets
logró pasar a la siguiente ronda y en la
siguiente ronda se enfrentará a Diego
schwartzmanella argentino quien logró
una muy buena Victoria ante nuno Borges
de Portugal La decepción es para las dos
latinoamericanas en Lisa de la del día
de hoy por una parte de la colombiana
Camila Osorio y por el otro la Argentina
Nadia poderosa ambas perdieron sus
respectivos partidos para quien continúa
Eso sí la luna de miel con París es para
Elena arriba Aquino la cabeza de serie
quien no necesitó sino de dos sets y una
victoria muy rápida para acceder a la
siguiente ronda quien también está en la
siguiente ronda es la cabeza de serie la
ha estadounidense Jessica pegule quien
es muy consistente ella ganó el primer
set y luego pues pasó la siguiente ronda
atrás el retiro de Camila giorgi su
rival italiana de el día de hoy y
terminamos por supuesto con leslina la
ucraniana quien regresa al circuito
después de una lesión después de ser
mamá hace tan solo seis meses y logró
una importante Victoria en tres sets una
buena batalla para la ucraniana que pasa
También a la siguiente ronda La
decepción por parte de los franceses que
hoy perdieron a sus dos mejores
jugadores
ambos eliminados del torneo